[موسيقى]
موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قال وزير الخارجيه
الروسي
واشنطن حولت اوكرانيا الى خطر وجودي على
روسيا ووصف الغروف منظمه الامن والتعاون
في اوروبا بالكيان الهامشي واتهم النيته
بالسعي لفرض هيمنته على العالم
بدوره قال الامين العام لحلف الناتو ان
الحلفه سيدافع عن كل حلفائه خاصه في
الجانب الشرقي من جهه اكد مسؤول الامن
والسياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الى صياغه نظام امني جديد في القاره
الاوروبيه
عرب الرئيس الامريكي عاقبه اجتماعي قمه مع
نظيره الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون في واشنطن عن
استعداده للحديث مع الرئيس الروسي فلازم
اذا اظهر رغبه في انهاء الحرب على
اوكرانيا
من جانبه قال الرئيس الفرنسي ان بلاده
تدين جرائم الحرب التي ترتكبها روسيا على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه واكد اهميه ان يكون
هناك دفاع اوروبي قوي وفعال
قال مجلس الامن القومي التركي انه سيتخذ
الخطوات اللازمه لمنع اي نشاط لما وصفه
بالتنظيم الارهابي في شمال سوريا وفدت
مصادر محليه للجزيره بان الجيش التركيه
قصروا المواقع لما تعرفوا بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في محيط مدينه منبجبي في حلب
ومواقع اخرى في ريفيه الحسكه والرقه شمالي
سوريا
كشف المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
ان الوزير لويد اوستن ابلغ نظيره التركي
خلوصي اكار معارضه الولايات المتحده
القويه لاي غزو بري تركيا المحتمل في شمال
سوريا
طالب مظلوم عبد القائد العام لما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه روسيا بتحمل
مسؤولياتها كونها دوله ضامنه لاتفاق وقفه
اطلاق النار مع تركيا وباعلان ما وصفه
بالمواقف الاكثر حزما
افادت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه بان المنظومه
الدفاعيه الاسرائيليه وضعت في حاله او
وضعت في حاله استثمار حول غزه تحسبا
لعمليه انتقاميه من الجهاد الاسلامي وكان
شابا فلسطينيا قد استشهد واصيب ثالث خلال
اقتحام قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مدينه
ومخيم جنين ونعت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
الشهيدين وقالت انهما من قاده كتيبه جنين
وتعادت بالرد في المقابل تعهد رئيس
الحكومه تصريف الاعمال الاسرائيليه
بمواصله محاربه ما وصفه بالارهاب دونها
تاهل المنتخب المغربي لدور 16 من كاس
العالم قطر 2022 بفوز على كندا بهدفين ل 1
ضمن المجموعه السادسه ليبلغ بذلك الدور
ذاته للمره الثانيه في تاريخه بدوري تاهل
المنتخب الكرواتي الى الدوري القادم
بتعادله مع بلجيكا دون اهداف
ختام الموجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]